[Música]
bienvenidos a estados unidos el país
reabrirá sus puertas a partir de
noviembre a todos los pasajeros
extranjeros totalmente vacunados que
lleguen por vía aérea a principios de
noviembre pondremos en marcha protocolos
estrictos para prevenir la propagación
del joven 19 por parte de los pasajeros
de vuelos internacionales a eeuu
exigiendo que los adultos extranjeros
que viajen a eeuu estén completamente
vacunados además de presentar un
certificado de vacunación contra el
cubil 19 los viajeros tendrán que
someterse a una prueba tres días antes
de viajar a eeuu y respetar el porte de
mascarilla las compañías aéreas también
pondrán en marcha un sistema de
seguimiento de los viajeros la unión
europea acogió con satisfacción el
anuncio tras meses de una prohibición de
viajar que ha mantenido separadas a
miles de familias en los últimos 18
meses
un paso esperado desde hace mucho por
las familias y amigos separados y una
buena noticia para las empresas
seguiremos trabajando por la seguridad
de los viajes la decisión beneficia en
total a 33 países entre ellos brasil
india china iraní sudáfrica también fue
muy bien recibida por las aerolíneas que
presionaron a la casablanca durante
meses para que se levanten las
restricciones sin lograrlo a tiempo para
la temporada de viajes de verano si bien
las fronteras aéreas de la unión
americana se abren así para millones de
personas
washington extendió las restricciones en
sus fronteras terrestres los viajes son
esenciales como el turismo por parte de
extranjeros seguirán en vigor para
méxico y canadá al menos hasta el 21 de
octubre